the virus is now out of control
international flights have been banned
international borders have been shut
and there's now severe disruption of
british ports
make no mistake this is now a real
emergency now i have faith in the
british people to
once again step up to the challenges as
they've done at every stage of the
pandemic
but they expect the government to do the
same
we can have no more over promising and
false hope
no more confused messages and slow
decision making
we need strong clear and decisive
leadership
the prime minister needs to be straight
with people about precisely what's going
on and precisely what he is going to do
about it
he must address the nation today after
this morning's cobra meeting
and then hold daily press conferences
until the disruption
has eased i renew my pledge to act in
the national interest
to help us through these dark and
difficult days
we will support further restrictions
where they're necessary
we will work with the government to help
businesses get through the winter months
and we will offer constructive solutions
to keep our nhs open
and the vaccine distributed
as we struggle against the pandemic and
the profound health and economic
consequences of it
making the case for our united kingdom
could never be more important
we entered this pandemic together we
face the enduring
challenges of the pandemic together
we will come out of it together
and we must rebuild together the duty to
rebuild will be a
shared duty it's not a duty
just in england scotland wales or
northern ireland
it's a duty across all four nations
together
and believe you me future generations
will
not forgive us if we shirk that
responsibility